- He's the only artist
we've ever met with who was
like, actually social
hacking on Instagram.
And then he's doing cool
things with the fans
that Quinn put me onto where he's like,
he told all the kids,
"Like yo, play my new song
over the intercom in your
school and I'll feature you,"
kids are getting suspended,
they're getting suspended
from school.
- That's what's up!
- So he actually had to like, stop.
- So if he did that
and he's doing hacking,
like what you were
talking about with Dunk,
then you're gonna win because you have
actual music talent, that I already know,
and then the only other part that matters
is distribution, and you are naturally,
it comes natural to you,
to hack distribution.
I always talk about the
example of P Diddy going on TRL
or when I wear Christmas sweaters
court side at basketball games.
It's just understanding
what's gonna get you heard.
- What's gonna get you,
yeah, you gotta do it.
- The end, the end, its only two things.
Is it good enough and will
people fucking hear it.
- That's it.
- Straight up.
That's good man.
- He's into retro brands,
they're saying they wanna
bring Gap back, like,
it's real cool but what they.
- You know what, all you fuckers, you know
what's amazing about you youngsters?
You guys are coming with so much more
entrepreneurial savvy than
the crew that came before you.
Everybody is trying to be a
mogul out here, it's cool,
it's good, man, that's how you really win.
Dollars are more interesting than cents.
And everybody was settling
for cents, you know?
Everybody was settling for cents and then
Puff and Jay-Z and Birdman, those guys
deserve a lot of credit, They
started to create a framework.
So good, makes me happy man,
good for you, how old are you?
- 18
- (laughs) That's what's up, man.
- So young, man.
- Yeah man, is there
anything I can help you with?
- Yeah, you're already helping me.
- I know, I know we've
been helping, but like,
we helped without you asking,
we'll help if you ask too.
You let me know, music in the
vlog, if you want to like,
my number one recommendation,
the same thing
you're doing with kids
in school, go hard after
Youtube vloggers and get your
music in their fucking vlogs.
- He just told me that too.
- It's the number one.
You get Jake and Paul
to put your music in so,
or Casey, or, and by the way,
those are the ones, just, I
know them and they're big,
there's fucking 100,000 vloggers.
- Yeah, to really help, the
best help, would be if you
could reach out to
them, I don't know them,
so I just, send it to them.
- Okay, I'll put them on,
and the way I'm doing that,
I'm already doing it
the right way, notice?
- Put it in the playlist.
- Exactly, first I put it in the playlist
'cause it's authentic, then now
I sit, the reason he's like,
listen, the guy I just kicked out is
looking to get me millions
of dollars, and I'm gonna
kick him out because I
want to get a sense of you,
'cause then if I'm, like, with it,
like from a good spirit
standpoint, then it's just
gonna make us wanna do it
more, like as soon as I heard,
like that one story, the speaker
thing I'm like cool, good.
Now I just have to do,
this is very real to me,
I just want to make
sure kids are good kids.
Like, you know what I mean?
Like I don't need you punching girls
or like doing dumb shit.
But once I understand the
person is good and smart
I'll fucking, by the way it's selfish,
I'll fucking give, give, give, give, give,
'cause that means you're gonna win,
and one day when you're in front of
90,000 fucking people in
London and you'll be like,
"Big shout out to my homey
Gary Vee who put me up for it,"
I'm not, I'm not Mother
Teresa, I'm just smart.
- [Woman] Right.
- And by the way, even if you don't,
I don't have that gear
where I'm like, "Fuck,"
you know this about me,
"We put him on why aren't
they doing," we're like,
"I have no expectation of
others, I just do the right."
- Play others, others.
- Never, 'cause you know this,
I'm gonna get mine
anyway, I don't need you.
So I don't need anything from nobody,
I'm doing it, and if
four out of every nine
do the right thing, well
four is better than zero.
That's the way to do it,
that's how you do it, you understand?
- Yeah, I know, I do give
credit to everybody always.
- Good man, yeah, listen, listen, listen,
you're gonna learn
'cause you're gonna win.
You know, people have different
interpretations of what help is and isn't.
People have met with me
once and think, like,
you know, like, you know what I mean?
You're gonna feel that, but the key is,
as long as you're judging
yourself and you know
you're doing the right
thing you'll be set.
Collaborations in your music, too.
Not, not up but wide, let me explain.
Not sitting here and being like, "Oh shit,
we gotta do something with
Gucci Mane or 21 Savage,"
or something like that,
Post Malone, like, no.
- I'm doing hip hop music and stuff.
- Well, that's where I'm
going, are there people
in country or pop or
jazz that are coming up
like you too that you
just like their flavor,
or, I thought Logic did it
right, like, or just in culture,
with fucking auto tune
even Boyd could sound good.
Like what if somebody's just
winning in life, Baby Ariel
just put out music, like, I
don't know, it just feels like
almost anybody can get in
the game in certain ways
with the technology advances
and post production,
so just being smart, you know?
- Yeah.
- Like, like Russell Westbrook to like
some girl that's got 19
million followers on Snap.
You know what I mean?
- You have 19 million followers on Snap?
- No, but that's just an example. (laughs)
But I love that you asked
that question, what's up, man?
- Me and him have been
reaching out to people
from like, other countries,
we have like other artists.
- Well this is our big
strategy, we think what's
going on in Latin America is real as fuck.
Like, you know, it's very
clear that American kids now
don't give a fuck, that they don't
understand what the words are saying.
- Yeah, we actually had someone not
in Latin America but in Russia
- Love it.
- Who is probably the biggest
artist in Russia right now.
- Exactly what you just said,
I'm working on different music
genres that move into pop,
you know what I'm saying?
- Hell yeah.
- Then I got songs with
like, where they from, Spain?
- Spain, Italy, Russia.
- All that, there's a
young lady in Sweden,
- Yeah, we have a young lady.
- All those people so, you know like,
it's about just expanding.
- Can I give you a good piece of advise?
- Yeah.
- Be patient.
- Yeah?
- That's the only thing that,
that's your kryptonite right now.
You clearly have your shit together.
The only thing that's gonna fuck you up
is 'cause you know it's gonna
happen, you can feel it,
and sometimes youngsters are just like,
"Fuck, why hasn't it happened?"
Like 13 months from now,
like, happen like that song
that completely changed shit,
and then they start doing shortcuts.
- Yeah, what do you mean
by, what kinds of shortcuts?
- Signing with somebody
dumb, doing a collab
with somebody dumb,
talking about something
they don't believe in just 'cause
they think it will make a
song popular, they deviate.
- Yeah, so you're saying
just stay down, stay down.
- Hundred.
- Best advise, true, I give that advise
to everybody, just stay down.
- A hundred percent, but
when you got real talent
and you're on the cusp.
- It's always gone work out.
- Always, but what happens,
the reason you're at this spot
is 'cause you're living that life.
Just from an old man's standpoint,
this next chapter is
the most important one.
This is the one that decides everything.
It's easy to stay down when
there's nothing to go up to,
but when you're on the cusp.
- It's hard to stay down.
- That's, it's what I do,
it's hard, like, I'm fucking,
I won, but I'm trying to
win the whole fucking thing,
so I'm just eating shit still.
- No, yeah, I know
exactly, and that's what
I've been telling him, right
now there's more to lose,
know what I'm saying?
More stuff coming at me.
- You're on the cusp.
♪ Try to run that game on you ♪
♪ You hittin' on me, that's shame on you ♪